California es el único lugar del mundo
donde puedes ir con una camisa hawaiana
y unas botas tejanas sin que nadie se
te quede mirando. No sólo es el estado más
grande de Estados Unidos sino también
el más rico. Es más, si lo comparásemos
con el resto de países del
mundo, sería la sexta economía del
planeta. Por encima de España, Francia o
México.
Y precisamente, por eso, os va a
sorprender si os digo que California
tiene una crisis de deuda tan bestial
como la de España o Grecia.
Tal cual, el mismo sitio donde está Silicon Valley,
donde está Hollywood, donde la gente
práctica del surf como si no existiera
mañana. En ese mismo lugar,
el gobierno ha tenido que recortar los
sueldos de los funcionarios, cerrar
escuelas y hasta algunos se ha llegado a
preguntar si serían capaces de pagar
las pensiones de los jubilados. Flipante ¿verdad?
En los últimos dos años
parece que el gobernador del estado,
Jerry Brown, ha sido capaz de poner un
parche a este problema de deuda, pero
todavía quedan muchas dudas abiertas.
¿Es una solución pasajera?
¿Volveremos a ver a los californianos
caer por el abismo de la deuda?
Hoy vamos a responder a todas esas
preguntas, pero antes vamos a mostrar esa
California que no sale en las películas.
California es la región con
más desigualdad de todo Estados Unidos.
Todos conocemos las empresas de Silicon
Valley, de hecho esta zona es una de las
más ricas del mundo con un salario
medio de más de 55 mil dólares al año.
Pero, 100 kilómetros más allá
esta Central Valley donde el sueldo
medio no llega ni a la mitad.
- "Actualmente en el sur de California hay
3,2 millones de personas viviendo por
debajo del nivel federal de pobreza".
Y, ojo,
todo esto teniendo en cuenta que
California tiene muchísimos más
programas sociales que el resto del país,
y que su sistema fiscal está pensando
para que paguen más quienes más tienen.
Por cierto, que esto tan bonito que está
sonando, es la música que nos ha
compuesto Mikel Bilbao
exclusivamente para este canal.
Entonces, ¿Por qué hay tanta desigualdad?
Lo primero que hay que tener en cuenta es
que California es el hogar de muchas de
las grandes fortunas del mundo.
Lo segundo es que el 30% de la
población son inmigrantes y muchos de
estos nuevos ciudadanos tienen trabajos
mal remunerados y no pueden acceder a
las ayudas públicas que ofrece el
estado.
Los que seguís Visualpolitik desde
hace tiempo, recordaréis éste vídeo en
el que os contábamos cómo los
inmigrantes, concretamente los
latinoamericanos, progresan muy
rápidamente. Pero mientras lo hacen
conforman ese grupo de población que
está por debajo de la media. Media que,
por otra parte, está artificialmente
inflada por el efecto de estas grandes
fortunas. Pero la principal razón por la
cual hay tanta desigualdad en California
es su ley de vivienda que es una de las
más restrictivas de todo Estados Unidos.
Construir una casa en California es
prácticamente imposible.
Necesitas muchísimas licencias y,
además, el suelo está tan regulado que
apenas queda espacio libre para hacer
obras nuevas.
Conclusión: en California es carísimo
comprar una casa. Para que os hagáis una
idea, en el Condado de Orange, el precio
medio de la vivienda está por encima de
los 600.000 dólares.
- "El coste astronómico de la vivienda en California
está llevando a muchas familias a la pobreza".
Es decir, que cada vez hay más
diferencia entre aquellos que han nacido
en California y que pudieron comprar una
vivienda hace 30 años, y aquellos que la
tienen que comprar ahora. Esto significa
unos beneficios extraordinarios para los
propietarios, y todo esto también se
nota en los alquileres: un apartamento
pequeñito en San Francisco nos
costaría unos 2.300 dólares al mes y
el sueldo de una empleada en una tienda
normal estaría entre los 2.900, así que,
hacer las cuentas. Y ¿qué hace el gobierno
para evitar tanta desigualdad? Pues crear
más y más programas sociales, y esta es
la primera razón para explicar:
California gasta cada año en sanidad
más del doble de lo que gasta Texas, y
lo mismo ocurre en pensiones, programas
sociales, viviendas de protección
oficial, subvenciones, etcétera.
Los que veáis este vídeo desde España, no
os sorprenderéis mucho, porque en Europa
estamos acostumbrados a que el gobierno
gaste mucho en estado del bienestar. Pero,
para lo que es el estándar de Estados
Unidos, California es con diferencia el
estado que más gasta.
y os preguntaréis ¿está mal que un
gobierno gaste mucho en estado del
bienestar? Pues no tiene por qué, pero
ese dinero tiene que venir de algún
sitio, y ese sitio son los impuestos.
En Estados Unidos tenemos por un lado
los impuestos federales que son iguales
en todas partes, y por el otro los
impuestos estatales que en cada sitio
son de un padre y una madre.
Por ejemplo en Texas no tienen impuestos
sobre la renta y todo depende del
impuesto sobre las ventas, que sería
algo así como el IVA.
Sin embargo, en California es todo lo
contrario. El IVA no llega al 8 por
ciento y el impuesto de viviendas es muy
bajo.
Sin embargo, el impuesto sobre la renta
es el más alto de todo el país y el 48
por ciento de la recaudación viene de
ese 1% más rico.
¿Dónde está el problema?
En principio, es buena idea que paguen más
quienes más tienen ¿verdad? Pues tenéis
razón, pero, ojo, también tiene sus
inconvenientes.
Normalmente, los ingresos de los ricos no
vienen de su sueldo sino de las rentas
del capital, es decir de sus inversiones.
Una persona como Mark Zuckerberg no es
millonaria porque tengo un sueldo muy
alto en Facebook, sino porque es el
propietario de buena parte de las
acciones de la empresa. Y esto ¿qué
significa? Pues que cuando la economía va
bien
Mark Zuckerberg pagará muchos
impuestos, pero si por lo que sea un año
Facebook no da beneficios, apenas pagará
nada. Conclusión, que California
recauda mucho o muy poco dependiendo de
cómo esté el ciclo económico. Para que
lo veáis mejor, vamos a comparar las
fluctuaciones de los impuestos de
California con los de un país tan
estable como puede ser Suecia
Este valle que veis aquí, corresponde a la
crisis del 2009. Tanto al gobierno sueco
como el californiano recaudaron mucho
menos ese año, pero si os dais cuenta en
Suecia
la caída es mucho menos pronunciada ¿por
qué?  Pues porque la recaudación del estado
sueco depende mucho de otros impuestos
como las ventas, la vivienda o los
sueldos de los trabajadores. Al depender
de distintas fuentes los ingresos son
mucho más equilibrados y estables.
Sin embargo, cuando las cosas en
California fueron mal para su gobierno
fueron rematadamente mal. Y esto significa
que no había dinero para pagar todo ese
gasto social.
- "Con una crisis de liquidez asomándose y
crisis fiscal cada vez más profunda,
California empezará a emitir deuda
hoy mismo". El gobernador del estado que,
por aquel entonces, era nuestro querido
amigo Arnold Schwarzenegger intentó
recortar gasto donde pudo. Congeló las
pensiones de los funcionarios, recortó
los sueldos de los maestros y, por
supuesto, cerró todas las obras que
estaban presupuestadas. Y, mientras tanto,
intentó tapar todos los agujeros del
presupuesto con deuda pública.
Por suerte, la economía en California
está lo suficientemente diversificada
como para que una crisis del gobierno no
se traduzca en una destrucción de su
tejido empresarial.
Pero lo cierto es, que cuando
Schwarzenegger pasó el testigo al
demócrata Jerry Brown en el año 2012
California tenía una deuda más grande
que la de Grecia. - "Durante estos próximos
cuatro años vamos a equilibrar las
cuentas y a vivir dentro de nuestras
posibilidades". Y ¿qué ha hecho Jerry Brown
desde entonces? Pues continuar la
política de recortes de Schwarzenegger
y, además, subir los impuestos. Pero, ojo,
sin cambiar el sistema fiscal de
California. Es decir, que la recaudación
todavía depende en muy buena medida de
las rentas del capital. Y aquí es donde
surge la división de opiniones, porque
los muy partidarios del Partido
Demócrata
dicen que Jerry Brown y California son
todo un modelo para salir de la crisis.
- "El éxito de Jerry Brown es una
lección para los demócratas a nivel
nacional". Pero también hay muchos
críticos que dicen que sí, que como el
ciclo económico a estado muy bien en los
últimos dos años en Estados Unidos,
Jerry Brown ha conseguido poner un
parche a la crisis de deuda, pero que en
cuanto a las cosas vuelvan a ir mal,
el gobierno de California lo volverá a
pasar muy mal. - "Moody's, la agencia de
rating, ha preparado una lista con los
estados menos preparados para afrontar
otra recesión, y California estaba en el
peor lugar, sólo superada por Illinois.
Y la pregunta es ¿debería California
cambiar su sistema fiscal? ¿Podrían
aprender algo de las economías de los
países europeos?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios, y si os interesa saber más
sobre la economía de distintos países
suscribiros a VisualPolitik
y seguirnos en nuestras redes sociales.
Podéis encontrarnos todos los lunes y
jueves en YouTube y, por supuesto, los
domingos en LaVanguardia.com.
Si os ha gustado el vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos
en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.